we've had breaking news andrew a lot has
happened since our last episode
yes kamala harris
vice president biden harris ticket
uh i'm excited no i got to know kamala
very well
on the rail it's funny like the the
different candidates
uh you're literally side by side
uh in in the case of me and kamala i
think i was a debate neighbor
multiple times yeah one time i smuggled
a handkerchief on stage for
uh she was just like hey you carrying
things on problem i was like sure
you know but but more than that
we uh we're in iowa back to back
multiple times really much more iowa
than anything else because she spent a
lot of time there
and i did too um but we have each
other's
contact info i got to know her husband
too on the trail doug who's a great guy
i'm excited
i think the biden harris ticket is
really hard to beat
you know it's like it it feels balanced
uh and kamala is a freaking
powerhouse where nature yeah like she'll
she'll she will be very very strong on
the trail
and make a lot of people very excited uh
so
it's it's great and the most important
thing always to me was
joe's desire for the right partner
because
he wanted someone he had the right
relationship with and it seems like he
had a relationship with kamala from way
back because she was
friends with his son beau and he was
attorney general and she was an attorney
general
uh so yeah you know it's a phenomenal
pick
in terms of your relationships with
candidates on the trail you were closest
i thought
with joe and kamala and maybe tulsi
forgot about corey my god sorry you're
right
um so selfishly from andrew yang
perspective this is pretty cool because
you're you're friendly with her are
friends with her
um but thoughts on the strategy of this
like in what what do you think besides
do i like the person do i think they're
a good leader what do you think from a
political standpoint optics standpoint
what are your thoughts on on the kamala
pick well i think there's a really great
balance again where you have
uh joe who's older than you
was like a generation younger uh
you have obviously the gender dynamic
the the race dynamic
uh it it's very balanced there's even a
little bit of an east coast west coast
thing going
the the right i watched fox news last
night because i'm always see interested
in what they say about
the vp pick and they already have tried
to brand her and ben shapiro came out
same thing said
kamala is a radical lefty and to me that
branding does not stick
i think no it really does as moderate as
they come i think it's insane to try and
call her that i think yes she's had some
california policies she's kind of been
wrapped up in or just by being a
senator from the san francisco or bay
area um
is one thing but she was an attorney
general
there is no she's a very moderate
sensible politician um
so i think that won't stick i don't know
to me she's already been branded and
throwing the nonsense
at her won't stick the way it might with
some of the other lesser-known
vp candidates he was considering yeah i
think they have to try
that i don't think it's correct or
effective uh but right you know at this
point they're in desperation mode
yeah it was it was fascinating like
hannity and
laura ingram were like this is the most
radical ticket the democrats have ever
run
you're like really not really i think
that i don't think that's correct
i don't know i don't know how many
moderates are really watching fox news
anymore but
i don't know but um that doesn't feel
right so
congrats to kamala and her team um
and i'm excited i think this is a solid
pick and we're and look the other thing
the other fact
the other piece of this is that all of
the democrats
fell in line which i think is rare like
we usually have rifts in our party
um and that was nice to see the rest of
the democratic
leadership and candidates all come out
and support her
and joe with the pick yeah i agree
congrats to kamala
and doug and the whole team your and you
know
win this thing yeah so we're going to
help which is exciting which brings me
to
other forms of helping and probably one
of the reasons many of you tuned in
because yesterday let yang
speak dnc was trending i think it got up
to number three in politics on twitter
but it was like it's top 10 in twitter
at least in the united states
so the the high level overview is that
the dnc came out with their
let's call it their speaker card um of
who's speaking all four days during the
dnc convention and we were left off that
list
which was a bit of a shock to us because
we've been in conversations with the dnc
um about speaking and have been given
what seems to be some prime time slots
throughout the week we are
you know expected to speak at the
convention be a member so
and then you tweeted out um you know if
i'm honest i was expecting to speak
in the sense of to speak with the people
on that list
so your react i think the world is
interested in your your real reaction
and also why this
um why this matters to you and and to
frankly our supporters
i think i commented to uh a journalist
that it's not like you or me were
jumping up and down
like yelling at anyone's ear being like
oh we need this spot we need that not
uh yeah um but that there is like a real
sense that
we have a lot of people that uh
supported my campaign
many of whom were on the fence about joe
uh
and i've been telling them we need to
get behind joe
and get trump out uh and i said this
makes that case a little bit harder to
make because one reason why people
who supported me would support joe is
like okay if yang is a
big part of the team then we can advance
some of the
ideas and policies that i ran on
it's just a harder case to make if it
seems like we are not
um being included and
to your points like i thought we were
being included
that was like the mystery it's like ah
like hey
like what what transpires here i want to
be clear people listening it's
it's not about us um like would you like
to speak sure but that's not the point
of this the point is we have a powerful
message and a lot of people that
supported it
and wanted this voice heard and it was
actually really touching the outpouring
of support so thank you if you were part
of it but like the outpouring of support
yesterday i was like wow
like that's so uh that was hilarious
people that were
forever people have hated on you forever
on msnbc remain nameless but they came
out and they were like andrew yanks
beyond there this is ridiculous
like that to me was um
i don't know funny and kind of case in
point touching invigorating
like i was gratifying i was like oh
thank you
that's so kind really because like it
did reflect on it for a minute um
because uh you know there are other
folks that are also not on the program
that ran
and um the fact that there doesn't seem
to be much of an outcry it was really
touching to me i was like oh wow
like people uh recognize what we did
yeah so
that thank you to everyone who helped
make make that happen
um yeah we're keeping making things
happening every day
twitter went nuts here we are we'll be
involved in the convention somehow
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode